[موسيقى]
انت طالق رساله وردتها عبر تطبيق واتساب
من هاتف زوجها بلال وبعد نصف نصف دقيقه
اتصل محاميها بالزوج طالبا منه الحضور الى
المحكمه للتوقيع على معامله الطلاق فالملف
جاهز وكذلك الماذ
والشهود والضيوف من انت يا هذا وعن اي
طلاق تتحدث ساله بلال فاجاب المحامي انه
طلاقك من زوجتك الذي ارسلته من هاتفك من
هاتفي تفقده بلال ثم اتصل بزوجته ليشرح
لها ان شخصا ما لم يحدده بعد يبدو انه عبث
بهاتفه وارسل منه رساله الطلاق رفضت
الزوجه الحجه واصرت على الفراق يا بنت الح
حلال ويا ام العيال ناداها بلال من في
مقامك لا تطلق بالواتساب وانت تعرفين انني
لا اخشى المواجهه ولو اردت الانفصال لفعلت
لكنني لن اجد مثلك سيده لدارنا لقد مررنا
بسوء تفاهم اكثر من مره ولم نحتكم للطلاق
بل للتلاقي ودوام الود اعلم ان الطلاق
حلال لكنه بغيض وابغض ما يكون في العشيره
الواحده
فا استهدي بالله وليس بالمحامين ولا
بالشياطين الى
العناوين وجودك حيا لا ينفي خبر موتك
ميلينيا في الفاتيكان شبه
منقبه عمره لترامب ومسجد لايفانكا
سياسي جزائري انا
طبال الهام حرب سوريا
جرافيك
مرحبا لم يكتشف الانسان ماهيه الروح
وعالمها لكن كثيرين تسلوا بالموضوع وسمى
بعضهم نفسه بالعالم الروحاني بالاذن من
الرئيس الايراني المهم هذا العالم
الروحاني او المنجم يدعي انه يستطيع اجراء
حوار مع الروح دون معرفه
صاحبها في الدوحه تم اختراق المواقع
والصفحات الالكترونيه لوكاله الانباء
القطريه خلال اختراقها بثت عليها اخبار
تقول الوكاله انها ملفقه بينما تؤكد صحتها
قناه العربيه وقناه سكاي نيوز وجمع من
المواقع الاعلاميه بحسب الخبر المدسوس هنا
المؤكد هناك فان قطر سحبت سفرائها من مصر
ودول الخليج ما عدا عمان وطردت سفراء هذه
الدول عمليا لم يحدث الامر لا سحب سفراء
ولا طرد سفراء لكن الخبر كان قائما وما
المشكله اصلا ما علاقه صحب السفراء بخبر
سحب
السفراء وجودك حيا لا ينفي بالضروره خبر
موتك يا جماعه الخير انا قررت عقد هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي لنفي الشائعات التي تحدثت
عن
اغتيالي عبر حسابي في
تويتر بعد قرصنته
واختراقه وقررت ان اظهر شخصيا
وعلنا لتبيان كل هذه الاكاذيب
الملفقه ودحض الباطل
بالحقيقه تفضل بس يا حضره المسؤول كلنا
شفنا وقرانا خبر اغتيالك وعلى صفحتك معقول
يكون كذب طبعا كذب ما انا موجود امامك
وبعدني حي
ارزق
تفضل هل ستشارك بالتشيع تشييع من تشييع
حضرتك كيف تشييع هو انا عم اتحرك وتنفس
وبعدني موجود بهذه
الدنيا
تفضل عفوا العزاء جاهز المعزون جاهزون ي
فطات الرثاء تم تعليقه النواح ابتدوا
بالنواح فور صدور الخبر معقول كل هذا يطلع
مش صحيح يا حبيبي يا ناس انا صاحب الصفحه
انا اللي تم اعلان اغتيالي وانا موجود هنا
بتصدق الواقع اللي تراه عيناك او الاخبار
الملفقه الخبر الاول الذي استهلت به
الوسائل الاعلاميه الزميله تغطيه ليليه
خاصه هو خطاب لامير قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
ال ثاني في احتفال عسكري يعلن فيه مواقف
مغايره للاجماع
الخليجي نفس الشيء الخبر ملفق بنفس عمليه
الاختراق بالنسبه لاعلام قطر والخبر مؤكد
بالنسبه
لاخرين بعد البحث تبين ان امير قطر لم يقل
الكلام الذي نسب اليه في الحقيقه لم يقل
شيئا لانه لم يلقي خطابا في المناسبه اصلا
لكن لابد من الشك للوصول الى اليقين فهناك
مؤسسات اعلاميه محترمه اخذت نص الخطاب من
الوكاله اثناء اختراقها كما تقول الوكاله
وفتحت تغطيتها دون الاكتراث بالنفي القطري
الرسمي والمتكرر ودون استضافه ما يعبر عن
وجه النظر القطريه فهل فهل ان روح امير
قطر القت الخطاب دون علمه بل بعلم العلماء
الروحانيين دونالد ترامب يراعي التوازنات
بين المجموعات الروحيه في العالم فيجعل
اولى جولته الخارجيه الرسميه مثلثه
المحطات اسلاميه ثم يهوديه فمسي استه هلها
بالسعوديه ثم عرج على اسرائيل ليصل بعدها
الى الفاتيكان وفي حاضره روما استقبل
البابا فرانسيس الرئيس الامريكي وزوجته
المسيحيه وابنته اليهوديه التين التزمت
اللباس المحتشم مع الحجاب الاسود ولم يكن
ينقص السيده ميلينيا اكثر من اربعه اصابع
من القماش الاسود لتصبح منقبه تتفوق
باحتشام واناقتها على سيدات البرقع والشد
والخمار في القدس وقف ترامب عند حائط
البراق بعبثه الاعتراضيه ووضع امنيته
السريه على ورقه داخل الحائط اما امنيته
العلنيه فكانت وعدا اطلقه على نفسه امام
نتنياهو بالبقاء دائما الى جانب
اسرائيل وساقط هذا الوعد لكم ان ادارتي
دائما ستقف الى جانب
اسرائيل بينما كان ترامب يؤكد لنتنياهو
عزم العربي على اقصاء ما وصفه بعقيده
الكراهيه عند بعضهم اسمعوا ماذا كان يدعو
نائب رئيس البرلمان الاسرائيلي بتلال س
مورتش من قتل وتهجير على الهويه
[موسيقى]
الدينيه
اربعه مواقف محرجه رصدتها شبكه رصد لترامب
في اسرائيل فهو تهرب من مصافحه بنيامين
ومن تقبيله ليقبل زوجته ساره على مراه من
ميلينيا التي رفضت الامساك بيد بعلها
وخرجت عن السجاده حمراء سيلفي وسوالف مع
العمه
[موسيقى]
ترامب
وقبل تلبيب كانت الرياض باكوره الجوله
وفيها ابرم اتفاقيات العصر التجاريه
العسكريه بما يتجاوز ال 400 مليار دولار
مخاطبا الناخب الامريكي بان زيارته
التاريخيه ستوفر ما يقارب مليون فرصه عمل
للامريكيين وبينما كان يشارك في القمه
العربيه الاسلاميه الامريكيه كانت محط حطه
سي ان ان الامريكيه تذكر بخطاباته
الانتخابيه المعاديه للاسلام ولدول
الخليج اعتقد ان الاسلام يكرهنا هناك قدر
مدهل من الكراهيه فيه وعلينا ان نعرف
التفاصيل كامله لهذا الامر انا اشعر
بالغيره وهذا امر مخيف لكن العربيه
السعوديه تجني مليار دولار في اليوم نحن
نحمي العربيه السعوديه ولا نجني اي شيء
مقابل ذلك
قمه الرياض خصصت لمكافحه الارهاب ويكفيها
انها عالجت ترامب من افه الاسلاموفوبيا
فاعترف بان
95% من ضحايا الارهاب
مسلمون لكن يا عم ترامب هذه النسبه ترتفع
في فلسطين ليصبح كل ضحايا الارهاب هناك
فلسطينيين فكيف طلع معك انه اسرائيل ليست
ارهابا وان من يقاوم احتلالها لارضه من
الفلسطينيين هو الارهاب لا يمكن لاي وصف
ان يصور مدى ضرر وحجم هذا
الضرر ان ان ما قامت به تنظيم الدوله نظر
والقاعده وحزب الله
وحماس المهم ترامب اعلن الحرب على ايران
من الرياض لكنه قال للحاضرين بان عليهم ان
يحاربوا الارهاب بانفسهم و لا يتكلوا على
الولايات المتحده امريكا فقط تبيع السلاح
وخد
الصيانه اما ابرز تهم ايران عند ترامب
فدعم لبشار الاسد كنظام مسؤول عن الارهاب
وانا اتحدث هنا عن ايران ايران هي العنف
الطائفي والارهابي بفضل ايران الاسد لا لا
يزال هناك يمارس جرائمه ترامب ايضا يدعم
بقاء الاسد في الحكم فالاسد يحارب داعش
وهذا الكلام ليس من الالفيه السابقه بل
قبل شهور قليله اما اذا بدل رايه بالاسد
بسبب قصفه خان شيخون بالكيماوي فقد فعلها
سابقا في الغوطه انا لا احب الاسد وكن
الاسد يحارب داعش وروسيا
تحارب داعش
وايران يكافح داعش الرئيس الايراني حسن
روحاني اكد ان مكافحه الارهاب في المنطقه
لن تحصل دون مسانده من طهران فعلا
واسرائيل فقط لم يتمكن الارهاب من ضربهما
اما زعيم ميليشيا ابو الفضل العباس
العراقيه اوس الخفاجي فرفع السقف عاليا
واستعاد معزوفه الشيطان الاكبر ان يجتمع
قوى الشر كلها في اطهر منطقه في الحجاز في
الجزيره العربيه بزعامه زعيم الشر او
قاعدي زعيمه الشر الشيطان الاكبر امريكا
شيخ اوس ما حلو نحكي بس هذا الشيطان
الاكبر قلبه وطيرانه معك في
البوصلي اعلن عن انتهاء مرحله التدريبات
والاستعداد للمعركه الكبرى ونحن على
استعداد المرحله القادمه ثلاث سنوات
تدربنا وخذنا المعارك وانتصرنا فلن تغلبنا
بعد الان تتساءلون لماذا الخفاجي يتحدث
بنبره اعلى من نبره القياده الايران
لان العراق هو من يحكم ايران وليست ايران
من يحكم العراق النائب عن التحالف الوطني
عبد الحسين
الزيرجاوي احنا جاي نحكم ايران من يتصد
لايران هم الذين يرتبطون بال محمد واد علي
نعود الى حصاه كاميرات قمم الرياض ترامب
الذي يتعاطى مع نفسه وكانه مازال مرشحا
للرئاسه الامريكيه او ربما استهوته لعبه
الانتخابات ولم يخرج من شغفها بعد ب
يستخدم الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
ايضا في حملته الانتخابيه المفتوحه ممعنا
في الاساءه لنزهه السيسي ول شموخ القضاء
المصري كلام ال المتبادل بين الرئيسين وصل
مع ترامب الى حد امتداح حذاء السيسي
الرئيس احترمكم وقدركم ولكم شخصيه متفرده
خدره على فعل
المح
ركز هيلاقي حذاء السيسي بيلمع شويه وحذاء
ترامب ايه مطح يمكن دي لغه
[ضحك]
جديده اثنان كانا في غير عالم عندما كان
ترامب يلقي خطابه وزير التجاره الامريكي
ويلبر روس الذي غطى في نوم عميق اثناء
خطاب ترامب في القمه مع انه كان يجاور
مقعد
ايفانكا اما الحاضر الغائب الثاني فجمع
المغردين الذين لم يواكبوا قمم الرياض من
زاويه تشكيلها تاريخا فاصلا في مستقبل
المنطقه بل تحولوا الى جيش الكتروني يتعقب
عائله ترامب اليوم وصل في تويتر هاشتاج
بنت ترامب لترند ويكون هذا هو الهاشتاج
نمبر ون يعني في ترند تويتر كل هذا نعديه
لكن المشكله والمخجل لما الصحافه
الامريكيه تلاحظ ه الهاشتاج اللي واصل
ترند وتتكلم عنه تجاهلت كل ما ما يحدث
امامك مما سيؤثر في مستقبلك على صعيد
سياسي واقتصادي ووجودي في المنطقه ثم تركز
على بنت ترامب العبث الكوميدي الذي رافق
زياره عائله ترامب كله في كفه وبناء مسجد
باسم ايفانكا في كفه اخرى علما ان السيده
اليهوديه بنت ترامب اضطرت للحصول على فتوى
من حاخام يهودي لاجل سفرها مع زوجها الى
الرياض السبت وهو يوم لا يتنقل فيه اليهود
بدون تكليف شرعي طبعا المسجد هذا بنيته
باسم الغاليه هي فانكا تزامن مع زيارتها
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لعلها تجد في
الاخره عمل صالح يدخلها الجنه باذن الله
اخوكم ابو سالم القحطاني دعوه للدخول في
دين الاسلام تلقاها ترامب من شاب سعودي
قدم له عربون محبه فاقام عمره على نيته
وهذه العمره بنيه سيد الرئيس ترامب ادعو
في هذا اليوم الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب الى الاسلام دعوه من نوع اخر اراد
صاحبها ان توضع على طاوله ترامب الزواج
ليس من ميلينيا طبعا بل من ايفانكا
ميلينيا عمرها ليس مناسبا السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته مس على مولاي خدم
الحرمين
الشريفي واطلب جاه وجاه وتكف الحزم العزم
تكفى الراي جديد ابي اطلب لي بنت ي الرئيس
ترامب الرئيس الامريكي كانان عسن الله
ورسوله تكفى يا ابو فهد يا عصابه راسي
تكفى كعان تكفى يا ابو فهد انا المواطن
بدر بن فهد بن عبد الله
الغيس الله يقدم اللي فيه الخير اخ بدر نح
نفرح لك ان شاء الله وعلى فكره كثير
لابقين لبعض بس عندها مشكله صغيره تحتاج
لمعالجه المراه متزوجه وعندها ولدين فبد
تحكي مع زوجها وتتفقوا الاولاد عند مين
بدهم يبقوا عندك ولا عند بالله تصبوا
هالقهوه وزيدوها هيل واسقوها للنشا مع
ظهور الخيل بالله تصبو هالقهوه وزيدوها ه
وقوها للنشا مع ظهور
الخير وزيدوها ه وقوها
ل في جديد محاضرات العفه دعوه من وزير
الاسكان الاسرائيلي واف جالنت الى اغتيال
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ان ما ارتكبه
نظامه تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء هو فعلا تجاوز
الخطوط الحمراء وانتم ملوك الخطوط بكل
الوانها سيد
جالانت مسيو بالنسبه لي حان الوقت لاغتيال
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد وبكل بساطه مع
كل التداعيات ذلك وعندما ننتهي من ذيل
الافع يمكننا ان نصل الى راسها في طهران
وفد من شخصيات وصفتها صحيفه تايمز اوف
اسرايل بانها شيوخ عشائر اردنيه من عمان
والزرقاء واربد زار تلبيب لمده خمسه ايام
وتخللتها موجه غضب الكتروني عارم في مختلف
الاوساط
الاردنيه المهم اجتمع الرئيس الاسرائيلي
رؤوفين رلن مع مترجم من العبريه الى
العربيه بحضور الوفد لماذا حضروا لانهم
يحملون رساله سلام
سعيدين متضامنون ايرلنديين حملوا رساله
سلام على طريقتهم
فاطلقوا حناجرهم وغنوا ووقفوا تضامنا مع
الاسرى الفلسطينيين وليس مع
سجانه بكتب با اسمك يا
بلاي الشمس
بتعي
لما
ولادي على حب ما فهبي
منجمه مصريه ترى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في بحر هائج مائج وهو يغرق ويغرق
اه هو اردوغان عنده مشاكل كبيره جدا هو
عارف لما حد بيقعد لما لما البحر كده
بينزل وميته تشي شمال ويمين هو عمال يقفل
هنا وهنا وهنا بس هي سايحه سايحه على
دماغه يعني فاول حاجه عملها قالك غير
الدستور على اساس ان هو هينج مش هينج مش
هينج مش هينج فاز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بما تقارب نسبته ال 100% من اصوات
الناخبين في حزب العداله والتنميه ليصبح
رئيسه مجددا بعد ان سمح تعديل الدستور
مؤخرا بالجمع بين رئاسه الجمهوريه والعمل
الحزبي وفي مشهد غير مالوف عربيا جلس رئيس
الحزب ورئيس الحكومه بن علي يلدرم اثناء
الاجتماع الحزبي في الصف الثاني وليس في
الصف الامامي لا شيء يمنع سياسيا عريقا من
ان يتحول الى طبال امين عام جبهه التحرير
الوطني في الجزائر جمال ولد عباس يؤكد نعم
نعم انا شيات ونص يعني طبال ونص للرئيس
بوتفليقه قلك جب
العباسي شيه لرئيس مشيت
ونص رفيق
السلاح عملاق وهو على المبر يستدعى على
عجل الى مقر الرئاسه فيحاول تلطيف الطلب
امام
الجمهور
فوق كم سيفرح ذوو مئات الوف الضحايا
السوريين عندما سيعرفون ان احدا لم يقتل
واحدا لم يجرح ولم يدمر شيء في البلاد فكل
ما جرى ويجري خدعه بصريه كاميرا خفيه
جرافيك الهام شاهين يعني عايزه اوصل للناس
ان الصوره اللي وصله اعلاميا هي صوره غير
حقيقيه وحقيقي مزوره يعني انا استغربت قلت
امال ايه الحاجات اللي بتشوفها دي جرافيك
دي ولا
ايه 40 نازحا سوريا يواصلون المبيت في
العراء على بين المغرب والجزائر ليس لهم
من يشاركهم ماساته الا العقارب في الصحراء
فهل عجزت الامه عن ايجاد ماوى لهؤلاء
اليوم احد
2152 لليوم بكون صارلنا شهر وست
ايام قاعدين في صحراء العراء بين الافاعي
والعقارب بالنيابه عني وعن 41 شخص بشكر كل
الشعب المغربي تضامن وقفته معنا بناشد
جلاله الملك محمد السادس يطول بعمره الله
يطول بعمره ان يعطف على اطفالنا وينقذ
اطفالنا من اعراء
الصحراء رمضان على الابواب ما بقى منه ال
[موسيقى]
القليل ختاما كان للغزلان حظيره عظمى
احتلتها الذئاب وقسمتها واعطت واحده منها
للخنازير تعتدي دون حساب ضعفت الذئاب في
الغابه فبرزت انياب الضباع تبحث عن
فرائسها في كل اتجاه وتخطط لسرقه ارض
الغزلان فعززت حظيره الخنازير واطلقت
الزواحف ثم ابلغت امراء الغزلان ان جماعه
الوعول تحضر لهجوم عليهم واكدت الضباع
للغزلان انها ستدافع عنها حتى الموت
فسارعت الغزلان الى تقديم نصف مخزونها من
المياه لكبير الضباع
كبادرة
على الخط الاخر ارسلت الضباع من يقول
للوعود انها ترى احقيه الوعل في كلا
الغزال
وكناسة واعطى كبير الضباع كلمه شرف لن
يترك الغزلان وحيده في المواجهه فصدقته
الا انه اولم في الليله ذاتها على شرف
كبار وحوش الغابه وطلب من بعضهم مؤازره
الوعول مؤكدا انه سيترك الغزلان لمصيرها
في حماه الوطيس ثم تتقاسم الوحوش الغنائم
التي لن تسلم منها ارض
الوعول الى اللقاء رمضان بجيله
هيقرب لنا
الاحباب
ويجمع لنا
الاصحاب
والرحمه حتفتح باب ونسامح من بعد غياب
والمحسن عمره ما خاب
ورمضان بقيله شوي شوي شوي اللهم بلغنا
رمضان
[موسيقى]
ا